enti come fai a solidale a grandissima
richiesta perché ce l'avete scritta in
migliaia rifacciamolo slide bendati
challenge questo ha superato i 10mila mi
piace convivevo adesso se superato i
10mila mi piace avremmo fatto la seconda
parte quindi se questo video super ai 20
mila mi piace fare una certa parte
quindi mi raccomando con l'inter anche
su science
entrambi ci metteremo bendati e dovremo
pescare i vari ingredienti sperando di
beccare gli ingredienti belliche
ingredienti brutti macchine togliere una
benda e vedremo come è diventato il
nostro slide e vedremo se vinco io team
azzurro oro giallo mostarda dovrete
votare alla fine del video qua nel
sondaggio se vinco io o se vince vitale
le frasi come sempre prendete i pop corn
frutta quello che lavora la cura in
serata
pronti a mandarci 32
ok siamo
vediamo un po ma tesoro questi cinque è
illuminato baratti 0 che lo sta
guardando ma allora cominciò a pescare
non abbiamo già la colla questa volta
quindi dobbiamo riuscire a pescare
qualche colpo a vuoto
speriamo di dedicare quanto io penso io
già pescato la insomma voglio poi
continuare e mettere la colla nella
ciotola seri fair centrare la sotto e
creare con lo slime mi chiamo sosa sta
scendendo la società si sforza sì ho
paura che questo allora cosa potrò mai
pescare basta certo che devi continuare
a pescare prendo questa c'è scelgo no
volevo dire pesco prendo da bendata
volevo dire ecco qua
e ok sta procedendo bene penso non possa
saperlo penso che possa scegliere dicono
cioè nel sesso soggetto che sta cercando
le cose però il tuo cercando qualcosa di
interessante
in che senso che stai cercando un umile
che fai guardando questo toccando ben
trovato qualcosa di interessante ma mi
sono solo saperlo se non vedi ecco che
ho sentito che bagnato allora devi stare
più attento mannaggia
che cosa cosa che mi sono sporcati di
qualcosa
vabbè si è incollato tutto ormai che
devo però devi stare attento
non so perché non so dovrò prendere ci
sto pensando che io sto facendo tutto
sto casino buttato a terra politico se
poi non per procedere perché devi stare
più attento io in realtà sto cerchiai
eccoli come fai a sapere che sono qui è
perché ho sentiti dalla forma del tanto
nella forma del lato una scelta credo di
aver aperto però cosa così aperto perché
mi sembra che è troppo grossa luogo qui
per far scendere tutti che io non so che
stai facendo non lo so c'è lo stesso il
suono mi sembrava qualcosa di strano
non so se messe armate sono mamma però
stavo andando a prendere una cosa lì e
vi scontrate con la sua mano che c'è non
so mi per scherzi io con gli scherzi non
faccio mai scherzi
allora che cos'altro potrei mettere è
lei che facendo che soggetto non
sembrano molto pericoloso tre rose
perché chissà che cosa sarei mettendo
secondo tech e colore stai mettendo il
noto caso è secondo
e se si tratta trattabile e tempi e un
rumore strano che meglio
secondo te e colore e per questo deve
essere un po per esempio era quello
barattolo grosso e quale tipo non lo so
io ci penso giallo allora cosa è certa
io sto ancora cercando vari ingredienti
penso che vi sarà uscito in una
schifezza sembra proprio brutto ei come
rubare la mia ciotola sicuramente sarà
uscito un colore bruttissimo che si
avvicinava nella mia ciò che ora
cercando qualcosa e non puoi mettere le
cose nella mia ciotola ormeggio stop ma
se hai visto posto così non so che cosa
metterla ma deve aggiungere
qualcos'altro subito il pari
[Musica]
allora cosa potrei prendere
poi prendiamo un altro ingrediente
[Musica]
chissà che cos'è questo non lo so
proprio
posso cominciare a girarlo set
[Musica]
troppo allarme già fatto chiesta puzza
di chimico chimica ma forse la tempera
che pozzo così tanto mi sono 70 tempora
[Musica]
non so chissà come sarà uscito il tuo ma
magari anche il mio sarà uscito
bruttissimo non lo so che c'è sento che
ti stai avvicinando a una puzza
inscindibile berlino sei stato tu
berlino
questa che non piace più gente a caldo
un po ho sentito rumore triade che amore
forse un berlino perché non tentiamo una
canzone nel frattempo
[Musica]
allora secondo me tu dovresti aggiungere
ancora qualcosa perché per saperlo non
lo so perché mi dicevi che c'è un odore
strano mentre qui c'è il tappo che
spezza il mezzo
[Musica]
non sono più mi sorprende e mi sento
puzza di catch up tv per chi si affaccia
tipo di come si dice se il colore a
tempera tempera chiesa impossibile
perché non c'è ketchup qua
[Musica]
insabbi chiesa per scaduto e sarà la
tempera che magari andata un po male
devo il caldo scommettono essi
[Musica]
[Applauso]
malissimo non mi per gli scherzi
sto facendo niente
[Musica]
perché una storia 5 rumore perché non sa
più cosa mettere adesso che l'ho
attiverò così che sono cominciati sito
altra band no sento il tuo respiro
[Musica]
perché così forte che penso censura
puzza fortissimi questo suoi
allora io mi sta che procedo adattiva
allora io procedo dotti mare lo slime
non vedo proprio niente come farò ad
attivarlo bene per fortuna attivarlo è
molto più semplice
non vedo l'ora di vedere questa sera
vestito bene mezzo ai galaxy cioè penso
che se ragazzi non lo so potrebbe essere
uscita qualsiasi altra cosa ma forte
visito gara secondo me questo galaxy
secondo me tu chissà che cosa hai
combinato
perché spero che sia uscito un galaxy
unicorno unicorni secondo metti il
tricolore lo volevi lo slime tutto
questo rumore berlino loro fattori più
la breve guerra mi passeresti per favore
il bicarbonato aspetta devo mettermi un
po io
[Musica]
scolare penso che lo sto mettendo nella
ciotola posso prendere la forma di
carbonato dove sei
io non vedo niente preso grazie è
proprio difficile fare climber dati non
so neanche quanto soluzione per mesi sto
mettendo come faccio c'è un autore e
berlino ea scoreggia correggi posso
avere la soluzione per lenti per favore
aspetta io non capisco se sì sto
attivando nord live perché non vedo
niente sarà attivo non lo so ma io
bambino allora il mio dovrebbe essere
quasi pronto anche se non lo so tra un
po viscido e da un treno cosa sia pronto
forse ho messo troppo troppo soluzione
berlanty 27 un po unisci tina è adesso
provo a prenderlo con le mani allora tra
un po è arrivato il momento di togliersi
la benda propriamente abbinare di
pistoia
ora il mio non è pronto però allora il
mio sarà di un colore spero che tipo
allora io me lo aspetto giallo
fosforescente coloro che sono al sicuro
di averlo fatto tipo viola per i
riflessi corro io invece penso che il
mio spera di un bellissimo cuffia galaxy
mini corno decordi ma siamo pronti a
togliere la band a dro massimi baceremo
di sport che verranno di lasciare uno
slide note ma che siano abbastanza
politica offre uno spaccato la bella
propri 32
[Musica]
che brutto tempo perché prossima volta
una mousse di cioccolato è straniera
cacchetta divertire è una mousse glitter
non basta fare questa parola che siano
in bilancio il mio pulsano perché non mi
chiamò perché il mio puzza
[Musica]
è questa che cos'è non lo so che l'ha
portata al successo tutti a fianco a te
non piace alla sera amelia più per te
non è che i problemi trimestri che
giochino marmitte dr berlino forza era
interessato ad ora che non ci fanno
staino per i che charlie non lo so
guarda me lo devi dire tu perché non so
che cosa hai fatto nello scorso video
elio l'ho visto come hanno visto tutti
gli altri come un fatto che mi hai
rischiato la cosa all'interno quindi un
dimenticato non è vero ti prego fornendo
però non mi sto profondendo l'hanno
visto tutti che è barato che messo le
cose nello slime non l'hai fatto pure
questa volta perché così siamo live sia
di sera perché di chiesa fine hai fatto
che tu quanto anno come questo punto non
detti che già poste in viaggio e chiedo
però se il caso a parte dello smart
anche nelle patatine andrai vecchia caso
dei poteri ad esso si sa che non può che
la maionese guerra che colora orribile
che mi è uscito quale ha messo nessuno
mai ha detto veramente sera volevo dire
mai doma una crema al cioccolato dal
palato grande
non metto il resto non vuol dire che
toccare terra trema cancello qua il mio
slime stupendo oddio è proprio da
cacchetta bene mi ha un colore recente
anche per la richiesta che tra l'altro
vi ho aggiunto anche dei glitter verdi
in un vaso
giusto è successo due volte che mi
rovini lo slime è colpa tua se mi
rovinano slime io sono sono super bravo
a stare attento lì a cercare di mettere
tutto dentro una foto e tu per nuovo
tesi fila mi hai rovinato con sopra
arrabbiato guarda ora se volete la
vendetta
andate sul mio canale è l'ultimo video
scrivete come dovrei vendicarmi nei
confronti di anita mangia bisogna
dimenticarsi sceglie così magari
sceglierò la vendetta più bella e farò
un video vendetta vita da che mi fai
questo posto di slide cioccolatoso che
sempre tutt'altro tranne che a quarata
scrivete i vostri consigli di vendetta
suo ultimo video del mio canale il
canale si chiama il canale di vitale
così io potrò vedere e prendere spunto
dalle vostre idee per fare un video
vendetta aidaa
lasciate un mi piace se volete vedere
un'altra traccia legge bendati che non
si sa come andrà la
e ora vi lasciamo qua quattro cartellini
su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video cliccando su quello che
preferite e voi la visione ciao
[Musica]